okay all right since the topic of the
night is yours let's go to you first doc
would having a public health care system
like Medicare for all
good question make it easier to deal
with but that's a great political
question would even get to you know what
a time for that issue in the middle of a
pandemic I mean I could see that really
helping Bernie but the question is would
a public health care system like medica
four will make it easy to deal with the
pandemic yeah absolutely it would I mean
I know we don't know what it looks like
just in general I mean you think about a
pandemic and or do you think about
illness in general and the the issue is
is that our you know everybody needs
health care and if you have somebody who
can't afford health care who's sick not
able to take care of themselves
those people are everywhere those people
I mean everybody is everywhere and so
really we are as healthy and as safe as
the poorest and least insured least
capable person of taking care of
themselves we're all in this together
and so that is a perfect example of how
we should all be enlisted what matters
presumably is universal coverage it
doesn't really matter whether it's a
single-payer system or multi pair system
right so it doesn't have to be medicare
for all it just wanna think about how do
people go to go to work sick now exactly
do they not don't a lot of people in
America even before this go to a lot of
people go work also not knowing that
they even have this right which is one
of the concern here is this issue of
work culture so we're telling everybody
listen if you can stay home if you don't
feel well just stay home and don't go to
work but there are a lot of people that
don't have a choice if they get to go to
work or not because they're not gonna
have a paycheck this is the only country
whose kids get sick and they can't they
have no family leave whatsoever
which is sort of I think one of the big
underlying issues we're gonna face in
the election right no I agree with you
completely and it's this issue of you
know are you gonna go to work if you're
sick if you can't put food
on your table if you can't pay your rent
if you're not gonna be taking able to
take care of your children yourself your
elderly parent I mean it's it's it's not
fair just to be able to say well you
know everybody should just do better and
and and be good public health citizens
and stay home we need everybody to do
better and that means also supporting
businesses that have good family
pro-family policies and making sure that
we who people who are business owners
are mindful of this also in allowing
people during this time period in
particular if people don't feel well
it's actually in your best interest to
let them stay home and to encourage
people to stay at home we're not a
country that prepares well are we well
we don't we don't we don't think in the
future and our rural hospitals are
closing and so when it comes to policies
like Medicare for all or if a single
payer you know system whichever one
we're gonna go down or a public option
that would not only help in situations
like the coronavirus but it helps in
just the obesity issues that you were
talking about addiction life
expectancies or Health metrics American
kids a five percent more likely to die
by age nineteen partly because of this
question of universal lack of universal
young people tired of us talking about
it as a country we've been talking about
fixing our health care system for 50
years like we know we know what the
solution is like let's get on with it
and let's start electing to do Obamacare
the Medicaid expansion was the biggest
single piece of it no question about it
you know and some states block the
Medicare expansion administration has
tried to sabotage it at every turn we
know they're important and would not
agree yes I mean no they do not like
Obamacare that is for juveniles right as
a true thing yeah that's not how we used
to do things in this country if we pass
something then they maybe got together
and then try to improve it that's
certainly what happened look I mean and
there-there's therapy
how does the same in the issue of
pre-existing conditions I mean that
Democrats won on that there that's a win
I mean across the meaning that
everywhere now no one now goes for it so
we gotta get rid of that right so there
are areas where the ball has been moved
the way that that progressives liberals
would want it to the patients would
overturn Obamacare and when then would
bring back pre-existing verbal support
is not the same as supporting a policy
that actually ensures it and again on
this radicalization of the Republican
Party which has pushed almost all
moderates people who would have been
happily or public in 30 or 40 years ago
a good example of that is our food
stamps Bob Dole and George McGovern who
could not have been farther apart
politically got together and said we've
got a hunger problem in America and we
have to do something about that if a
Republican did that kind of thing
with anybody any Democrat on the other
side in the Senate they might face some
of them because they were both talked
about World War two veterans is that
they both that's right a both remember
what it was especially Bob Dole they
remember what it was like to come home
and have the entire community take
Erika's Bob Dole was wounded do you
think the Democrat Party is not the
furthest left and it's ever been I mean
you keep talking about the radicalized
Republican party and there's no I mean
the democratic party I mean we have an
open socialist is the front-runner right
a simple statistic if you ask
Republicans who they are ideologically
two-thirds are more conservative if you
ask Democrats their split half liberal
and half either moderate or conservative
right we're at the voting patterns in
cars only the front-runner because they
have split we're all being awarded the
drug war and boo to judge a few people
right but if they're close to him okay
but if Buddha judge Bloomberg Biden and
Club Bashar were all one person who is
at your head
that would be the frontrunner and that
may happen in two weeks we may see that
Bernie Sanders may not be the
front-runner because three of them may
drop out or something like that and then
we will save so I don't I don't know I
don't think even most Democrats identify
as liberal no that's absolutely right
especially in our communities of color
where black Latino Native Americans they
are not flaming liberals as you would
like them to think that they are that
very moderate on social issues and very
liberal on it and the cashews they want
to see our government get back to the
job that we believe that it levels the
playing fields that it brings fairness
and that the mantra that Senator
Wellstone used to say is true for all
Democrats that we all do better when we
all do better and that's what we have to
get back to our Democratic Party in
order to heal these kind of divides
right now in order to with beat Trump
which is it's not gonna go well for your
boy it's just not it's no I'm sorry
because I mean this virus is something
he cannot lie his way I don't think no
but that you can't he said it was a hope
today what do you think about just that
just Anjanette what do you think about
that he said it is their latest hoax you
don't make it so he doesn't think as a
host of course it's not a hole he's
saying that what's the hoax is the way
that Pelosi and Truman or others are
saying there's been an insufficient
response that he doesn't know what he's
doing when we don't even know how many
cases we haven't no one's not yet and
but your point about about
accountability is important because he
can't if there are people that are dying
from this enlargement stock markets
really low yes Trump's gonna suffer I
wouldn't just write just said and your
boys not gonna go
we'll see we'll see what ends up at the
point I'm trying to make is just that
there will be accountability here so why
are people trying to force it before
it's there I've seen people with the
masks on the street now what we
occasionally you do and it just reminds
me that these America ace things these
things are not going to come here we
didn't think it was with terrorism and
then terrorism came here and maybe aids
I think was in the world before it came
here and now this and environmental
destruction on a level that other
countries have see it always is going to
come here we've had pandemics stretching
back yes he warmed into the Republic
actually New York City has a history of
color epidemics where they were stacking
up Irish and African Americans and
African American freed slaves down a
Lower East Side by the thousands over
the course of a few weeks so this has
been and you know people were saying
where's the government on this one so
I'm just saying the party's over in the
sense that this country has periods
where they party the gay 90's that gay
90's the Roaring Twenties the go-go 80s
there it and we've had it the last ten
years and then the party ends for one
reason or another we are going to use
any party's over right now I just think
we're gonna well when you lose six
trillion dollars in a week and people
are freaked out about a pandemic which
is inevitably coming I do think it's bad
gonna be a little less of a party it's
bad that was already here right so we
have the millionaires and the
billionaires and then you have everybody
else and so we as a party how part
people going out and kissing strangers
people are gonna be inside and taking
care of themselves a little more and
then we'll party again someday I promise
thank you
[Applause]
you